sanctum sink down sanctum is produced by
James Cameron sanctum is in 3d that
means you have to see it but you
shouldn't sanctum tells the story of a
team of cave divers who are deciding to
explore what the trailer calls the last
place man doesn't know about
it's like commonness crapload of places
on the earth people haven't been anyway
the cave divers are exploring this cave
and a huge storm happens of course that
for some reason no one was able to see
or predict or forecast ahead of time
while they sent large amounts of people
deep in a cave where they would become
flooded and trapped by any type of
rainstorm so we have this team of cave
divers who are exploring this cave
suddenly now they are trapped down there
by a whole bunch of rocks lots of water
that's filling the place up and they got
to find a way out and the only way they
can get out is to go deeper inside to
hopefully find a way to get out now this
is one of those movies that's made
purely to accomplish one thing they
don't care how they accomplish it it's
at the expense of a whole bunch of other
things as long as they can accomplish
this one thing then they'll be happy and
that is to make a good looking 3d film
that they did the 3d in this film is
good the locations the underwater
sequences the cave sequences they all
look excellent I was completely
convinced that they were really in that
environment it all looked wonderful the
acting in this film is awful it is like
a sci-fi Channel original movie
it's like Mega Shark vs octopus or
something
except it's not fun this script the
writing the dialogue is just bad that
bad there seems when the characters have
to cry and it looks like they're trying
not to barf it's some of the worst
acting I have seen recently
it says produced by James Cameron on
this film I have a feeling that that had
something to do with the filmmakers
saying hey can we use those cameras you
made an avatar with and he was like in a
movie that made me millions of ducklings
and that the greatest person alive
sure you can use them pay me lots of
money okay mr. Cameron will pay you
whatever you want just let us use your
cameras but of course you can use my
cameras just put my name on the film I'm
the greatest and that's what happened
I'm probably wrong he was probably there
every day on set and told them exactly
what to do but that's just how it seems
when I'm watching this movie I'm being
honest with you this film looks
excellent the cave photography the
underwater photography completely
convincing very well done there are even
a few sequences in this movie where I
really felt claustrophobic and I felt
the weight of their environment and it
seemed real to me but the fact the
matter is I don't care what happens to
these people because they are all so
annoying almost every single or these
actors is unknown the lead actor is one
of the villains from Mission Impossible
2 and one of the cave divers is Ione
Gruffudd I don't know how to say his
name he's mr. fantastic and the
fantastic four movies and he's a bad
actor they obviously know what they were
doing and hiring the director in regards
to filming the underwater sequences
however those are the only interesting
sequences any of the scenes done with
just humans talking he'd thumb them just
the completely uninteresting totally no
style
nothing the scenes that were supposed to
be dramatic he had no sense of where to
put the camera and how to use it how to
move it and just terrible he obviously
is very good at directing the underwater
sequences or he has a fantastic second
unit director I don't know sanctum sank
and it's dumb sanctum I'm gonna give
sanctum 2 out of 4 stars simply because
I feel the environment was so well done
but everything else was just blah